you
[Music]
all right so hi everybody thanks for
coming to Helen Long's talk Helen's been
a friend of mine since my first year in
grad school at Berkeley she was in the
office and welcoming me and actually she
called me to tell me I even got into
Berkeley which was even cooler than that
in 1990 was something but today
Helen has worked here which everyone in
this room knows Helen already but she
worked here for a very long time at MSR
and then she went off to found a company
called six crickets which is her dream
to make a nice startup and it's all
about getting kids to go to summer camps
so I want enough it's more than that how
does it tell you all about it there you
go
thank you so much Andy for having me and
thanks everyone for coming here and it's
so great to see everyone and it feels
like a long time but I am very happy and
to be back and share with you about what
I have been doing and as you know in our
that the there's such a big buzz about
artificial intelligence whatever you do
you've got to do something about it but
actually here there's a really practical
usage and and I will I will share with
you about that
so what about summer camp planning and
and so let me first provide you some
context and I will I think this context
would like to the formulation of a very
interesting actually open research
question that in fact nobody has solved
which is very interesting and which we
call the problem to be scheduled
recommendation I won't talk about
challenges and approaches I will not
show you the formulas and and so on but
you get some sense on the directions of
the approaches that we have done and
actually that technologies live our
website a two-year-old star lab can also
have cutting-edge technology in it which
I feel very happy about so a tech
transfer has really happened right there
now so I will also show you some demos
and so on and then conclude
so I'm a mom and what really led me to
creating six crickets calm really from
my own pain when my children turn five
years old and seven years old and all
the sudden Award of activities became
available and it's such a painful time
for us parents to actually figure out
you know a summer camp schedule or
after-school enrichment activity
schedule and this is actually daily life
stuff parents need to make sure this
three months of summer that children
needs to be arranged somehow and fun in
Richmond learning and fun would be often
a desired thing for parents and for
children but we I quickly realized that
in this space this feel the technology
doesn't seem to have you know today you
ruber a ride in second and you Airbnb
home away from home but one comes to
planning for our children's sometimes
daily enrichment activities or summer
activities it takes a parent's for hours
and days and weeks and to finalize this
really speaks thought a deeper problem
to me but let me just tell you on the
surface what we poor parents have to go
through first of all we need to figure
out what are some of the interesting
enrichment summer camp providers out
there you get of that list of websites
and names from from your Google surgeon
from other parents then you go to relate
each website manually parse the age
manually parts where they might be
manually parse the interest which
programs then you write down this
program may be working and and for
sports and there's a chess and there's a
sport they all you'll find the right
programs then you also still need to
figure out the program is happening for
these weeks that sport programs
happening for these weeks over the
summer over maybe four five weeks and
chess happening from these two three
weeks and the other signs can may be
very popular and therefore five weeks or
three weeks is already sold out and all
of these so you need to kind of see this
as all this information and create a
schedule that works for families
sometimes when you have one child is
very
complex I have more than one children
and it's it's actually very complex this
complex schedule coordination actually
points to a deeper computer science
problem which I will talk about that's
exactly the problem that I will
formulate and once you even figure out
the schedule and poor parents have to go
to every single website log in or have a
yet another password and also fill out a
very lengthy registration form it's not
just your name and email but also
parents information you mergency contact
doctors information insurance contact a
medical information and so on so that's
that's why you can see in the spaces
like uber and airbnb that's what 21st
century should be and this is a space
that's not yet in 21st century and it's
the technology support in next
investment
it lacks it's underdeveloped area that
really drive for disruption
so that also spells out a great
opportunity for for me
so what we have created is excreted comm
for parents that's a you know basically
providers on one hand parents you know
have trouble finding the right programs
and figuring out schedule on the other
side there MC C's in providers classes
and so six frigates comm is the online
marketplace where providers can list the
seat to sell six cookies calm and
parents can come to a central place to
search make a schedule for one or more
children across the width of the summer
or a weekday throughout a week for
school years and then pay and register
for the schedule full of camps or
classes in one go and then share that
schedule with with money you know France
to take cans and classes together so as
I hinted that schedule is essential
abstraction of our system yes how are we
this May oh that's a great question
gosh that's a topic question that I have
to under probably in this song the
question is how did we come up with the
name six cricket well it can inspire
beautiful logos no probably done wrong
answer
basically I
it I'm sorry let me you know at the end
we're not a marketing person we're bar
geeky and so what really led to this
name is that we need to find a name the
domain name cannot be pickin and it has
to sound good and playful and so we will
think more about it nice marketing story
in future yes it's like all the things
you mentioned you know as a challenge
for scheduling a summer camp are also a
challenge for thinking at college
have you thought about it how the whole
approach could help people find a better
fit for a college I wonder whether
that's a recommendation problem or the
schedule recommendation there are two
components which I'll talk about one
there's a scheduling the other one
there's a recognition
these are disparate areas and people
have done a lot of research separately
in the separate canceled research areas
and we happen to stumble on a problem
that needs to be both and you cannot
combine both trivially that would be too
expensive so I will tell a little talk
more about that later but that's a
really good thought I think that the
schedule recommendation we'll talk about
it does have broader impact for example
so today what we have come up with to
have a schedule recommended for children
that satisfy all your constraints and
including driving diversity and so on
and availability and so on and for
example like one application is you know
organize a fun outing for your circle of
friends maybe different Google friends
every weekend it's got to be event that
all of your friends love it's got to be
a group of friends that you would really
have fun getting together with and it
got to be the event is available and so
so there are broader there are many
scenarios that could benefit from that
formulation of that the solution that
that we came up with for that problem so
and so many people say well Helen you
you had a rule
good live and Mike Rosario you're a
principal researcher and you're founded
and you're managing a security and
privacy research group why are you now
selling cancer classes come on Helen
what a poor career decision you've made
I like to define my position I like to
define my solute my decision here I want
to first say that I am really inspired
by people like Jeff Bezos and I think in
the course of doing this startup I also
get to read more about these people you
know of course nobody's perfect but I'm
inspired by people like Jeff Bezos or
Elon Musk and the reason is that I think
they all see a future that's inevitable
and they so firmly believe in that
future that and they're doing Oh what
whatever they need and to get to that
future and so determined and so
persistent the absolute future Jeff
Bezos identified is that the Internet
here the web is here we've got to be
able to buy anything everything on
internet for the first eight years there
are people about him and the you know
even after IPO the stock crash and so on
and but he never failed to recognize
that vision and has always been
personally pursued that despite that
he's not a technology despite that he's
not a any experience in retail right so
similarly I so I draw also you know I
also feel comforted I'm I also have no
experience with Commerce or something I
was a computer scientist but I also
identified this inevitable future that
is today the way to education innovate
inside of schools it's way too slow it's
the ways innovating is like centuries
centuries of old the way of innovation
education has been in service groups
very slow and the innovation speed is
very slow and you know it's very hard to
make changes very hard to experiment but
nevertheless there is a place where the
education innovation is happening at a
much faster pace right there's 3d
printing has come around for a few years
and it's sold
for years but it has become very popular
over the past few years and and there's
3d printing summer camp and virtual
reality has you know has you know is
arriving in the mainstream and there is
a summer camp about virtual reality
storytelling so basically anyone who has
a hard to teach children has a great
ideas about teaching something and they
can have that class coming this summer
have that class this coming fall so the
way the new cool ideas cool teaching is
actually you can see a lot of media I
invite you to come and visit our website
you would be amazing the variety and
creativity of the programs that we've
seen bye-bye a lot of today's enrichment
providers already and a lot of them
actually they're also come from
distinguished background as well
so um no I don't well you mean in a
hundred years or thousand years
thank you
I cannot predict that the school will be
completely gone but I know that this
will be here to stay and this will lead
education innovation and yeah so the
speed of this innovation we really truly
push I really truly think that the
education division will be happening
here then it will impact the school as
well having school completely
disappearing in 20 years it's a little
hard to imagine yeah so then given this
context so and so what I really want to
do is to power this innovation and to
create an efficient market engine and
infrastructure for education you reach
medication space and and also - yeah -
essentially you know fundamentally kind
of making the impact for education for
children and so on so that's kind of
what really made me so excited about
this journey um
so well we have discussed so I have
talked a lot about this one product you
know a six cricut.com one-stop shop but
we actually we also have a kind of
ecosystem kind of solution where we also
support the schools for after-school
enrichment providing the right tools for
the operations to be much more fluid
allowing many more children to
participate in Richmond will also
provide operations support for the
providers to allow the providers to have
a much streamlined operations on their
back-end for their website for their
business and for the parents is the
product of the one-stop shop so that
they can have you know all the
information at their fingertips they can
complete transactions much much more
quickly so what we have is a one-stop
discovery of all the cams and classes
for children for a particular season
summer spring or or something and you
can do map navigation you can do
filtering and and then a key thing is
that we solve the scheduling puzzle that
I talked about you have you know cams of
various schedules from different
providers you need to kind of put them
together for one or more children
meaningfully that also
Commodus your own family schedule so
that the schedule deposit is up in the
sense that I will actually show you the
parents will be able to much more easily
to see where can fit into the schedule
and we also here apply the schedule
recommendation to assist more automation
to give more automation there and
remember you know there's another hurdle
is repetitive long registration form and
we also allow parents to book classes
from different providers using just a
single registration form and having you
know automatic invoicing with the
providers underneath simultaneously and
by having the schedule as a central
abstraction the parents can and that's
also the unit of sharing you can share
the schedule with others and kids can
take the same class at the same time
much more easily instead of in the past
you have to have a list of email and
phone calls and still not resolving what
to do together
so I here I'm showing some screenshots
and welcome people to surf the web to
serve our website so basically come here
or you can plan for all of your children
and you have to queue my kids some years
old a nine year old and here is for the
summer and near where we are with that
then you can come to lots of Khem and
right now this number is like fifteen
hundred can and you can have many
sessions so in you know ten mouth radius
you the parents are really trying to
figure out among all these you know
7,000 kids sessions classes how can I
figure it yourself yes with popular
organizer so if something some sense
it's very similar to Airbnb so the
people who rent out their rooms in their
houses will need to describe their room
and our Airbnb when people can find it
it's similar in that session and then so
everything here you may feel yeah this
may be similar to Amazon to go to some
of the things you've seen but when you
click on one where is aware this is will
look very different
well before I do that there's those auto
kind of navigation
in terms of locations categories you
know just lots of filtering as well
and when you click on one where and this
is what happens you click on one where
it shows you know for my children for my
children
Quincy seven-year-old and Colin nine
year old here are the weeks of the
summer but click on seein you know one
where it tells me where in the schedule
they will show up right so if you know
this class is available for both
children for this week as well as for
this week and the parent I can add to
schedule a to schedule can see this much
more easily we can also search you know
if it's available for one child not
another child then you can click on this
like search for this week for this child
so this kind of click saves parents or
they just hours of time before they have
to go to many different websites just to
achieve that one click ok these all seem
much better and once you build up that
summer camp schedule then you can pay
yes
J it's a girls-only oh really good I I
do not add that to the schedule so after
you build out the schedule so no matter
which classes which providers these
classes come from and you can all come
to one place and just pay that's it yeah
so here it's also kind of a little bit
similar to Amazon like you have all
these products from different places you
only pay one oh yeah and then you can
share the schedule and invite your
friends this is one we're sharing your
friend receives invitation can see our
schedule but they need to share back
with you to be able to see theirs and
once you get their schedule you can look
at their schedule they are like this one
you can add the same one to one of your
children so that's kind of basic slow
how this website function yeah but then
you may say wow that's too too much work
I still have to click so many times and
to figure out what I really want is just
give me a nice scheduling and I just pay
for it so that's exactly what I want
what I was thinking two years ago
that's feels yeah that's what I want
just give me a nice can schedule just to
pay for okay so that comes to
formulation of this schedule
recommendation so the problem here is
given the children's ages and where you
live and the past behaviors I recommend
a class schedule that satisfies the ages
the interest or social needs they have
to go to a certain friends and well
minimize driving so you don't want to
for this week send the children you find
the calves but there are two ends of the
time then that's not practical so that's
a constraint
cross the students and you also don't
want to have you also we also want to
maximize the topic diversity across the
time slot like this week that is soccer
next week they shouldn't do soccer they
should do something else so how can we
come a schedule across all these weeks
say of the summer and and that satisfy
all these constraints
sometimes across students sometimes
across time slog and also with as you
can see seven thousands of classes to
figure out so that's kind of the problem
the challenges are unlike the
traditional scheduling problems where
before you often just schedule for for
one person and now you're scheduling for
multiple students like in the
traditional optimization you often maybe
just scheduling just for one student
another challenge is that this is math
I'd imagine though drawn constrained and
premises there's you know there's time
there's there's ages inches and minimum
driving across students diversity across
time slot so that quickly have a much
larger search space so then the
scalability needs to be we really need
to have a solution that skills given
these strong constraints skills to tens
of thousands of classes here round drive
time do you actually have a route setter
you know sensitive to time of day yes so
basically we need to if there are two
camps if we can only find two camps
they're not at the same time they're not
at the same camp we also need to make
sure that the start time is that a
reasonable time so you can actually get
you from one to another
yes exactly right yeah
sure you also offer a carpool
recommendation to power with children go
to camp has a great idea I think many
people want that that's a to do yeah
so once they share the schedule I think
the next thing is couple yeah good point
yeah and also in this problem we also
want to incorporate the user preferences
over the classes you know I didn't like
you know I don't want this class I want
at this class students and so on so this
kind of purposes over the classes also
needs to be learned and so we need a
tight integration between the item
recommendation and the scheduling yeah
so basically our basic approach is that
we use recommender system methods to
estimate child session suitability so
this child this session can can work for
this child because of the age and
location constraint and and so on and
then we'll use an integer linear program
to find a schedule that maximize the
suitability of the selected sessions and
respect other hard constraint on cost or
driving distance and class availability
so and then there there's you know some
of the innovations and ongoing work
involved problem driven cost function
for learning so we want to train the
scoring function using the cost function
derived from the feedback on a full
schedule rather than individual user
item pairs we also want to integrate
drawn constraints and scores like yeah
we talked about this like minimize
driving across students and maximum
diversity across time slots and dealing
with thousands of classes and there is a
trade-off sometimes we may not be
perfectly optimal but we because of
these thousands of classes available to
make the schedule we also need to make
sure our results our schedule can come
back within 10 seconds and the last way
that the area that of the challenge is
the user interface to guide the
recommendation scheduling how can the
user
giving certain tuning that to guide the
recommendation for example I'm so I'm
okay to to be late I don't know so there
there are some kind of user can relax
certain constraints and to Allah
scheduled to happen sometimes when
you've a schedule is not available they
may be able to relax during constraint
so so we have yeah the first pose so
sure either console scheduled so that's
something that you get from that people
that use this use the tool is it like
yeah yeah is it like yeah you know how
do you see that yeah so basically if the
user says I don't want this item in the
schedule ah that's a feedback okay okay
yeah written feedback better but when
you say both schedules what is that what
schedule is basically I have a summer to
feel right what what I want is a
schedule and what why remove that item
it may not be it's more complex than I
don't like that item it could be that
yeah yeah okay and you don't ask people
why so that's a user interface sometimes
we also need to potentially to get
additional units or not so when they
remove item from the schedule there
could be multiple reasons maybe because
they don't like you know last week is
soccer and this week is martial artists
too much movement although it's good to
the to the system is a diverse but but
it's not like I don't like that provider
I just want something calm for that week
so it's more complex sorry this
combinatorial yeah so if you have
parents both parents because the other
finite resource
you've got busy job and time and
scheduling things I get your parents
schedules in there so that will
complicate big UPS is way back maybe
they can or you have an uber option when
neither can do it is it I don't know if
he knows where it needs to go where to
drop the kid off and I just think it's
taken care of
that's a great coin very originally we
were also something about okay we
shouldn't agree the parents calendar so
that we can do really intelligent things
but that's very challenging you because
you don't know what items are the
parents
/ right because when you are having
those meetings in whatever leadership
team and then this is a kid can't you
take the can no comparison to work it
out much actually that the pick up is a
really good idea it is really good
consideration I think it's doable yeah
thank you yeah so this thing we have a
basic version working for the schedule
recommendation and you can try it on our
website give a cup of children and see
what comes back
this will come back for my
seven-year-old an eye arrows on the top
you can see that it's the same camp from
Stone Soup theater that's a drama class
and the next one is a public speaking so
here that the Machine telogen sees not
as intelligent human these two are very
related you may want something different
but to the Machine they're they're
similar they're different actually then
the next one is about programming game
and the next one is about soccer and the
next one is about karate and the next
one is soccer again then it seems to be
running out of and then there's a task
and so on chess / coding so this
schedule could possibly just workable
but oftentimes it actually does automate
what I just did earlier while I was
trying to build up the schedule manually
trying to locate the camp close to one
another you know for the same week for
the children and trying to figure out
different topic for the next week and so
on so it actually does trying to
automate what I would do um yeah so so I
can conclude so we came up with the
schedule recommendation it's a problem
that at the cross of optimization
algorithm and recommender systems and
we're still doing more trying to trying
to understand more about what would be
the best way to come up with the best
schedule and to revise and to keep
learning as the user interacts with the
system
I give another scenario where the
scheduled recommendation could be useful
I think there are many scenarios where
there are people doing things together
I think schedule recommendation can be
useful and what's pretty cool is that oh
sorry there's the line that's not
necessary and I'm reusing some some
Facebook I give this the same talk at
Facebook I'm not edited out okay so
great so that's pretty much what I have
been up to and I will continually love
to get feedback and advices from from
our colleagues and I comes out to some
of the colleagues and ask them questions
and learn about yes Korea seems like the
constraint modeling is like right up
your alley I love you what is what has
been your challenges switching from
being a researcher into the CEO to
putting the other startup fund a great
this is model yes yes what I learned is
that actually being a researcher gives
you a very good to set for you to do
start doing startup is about it's a you
know a path no one has walked right and
research problem you you find that you
have a vision about a risk or problem
you also explore and find all kinds of
way and to solve it and here there is a
problem
there's the inefficiency in the you know
education in this enrichment education
space my goal is how can I remove it if
the inefficiency and how can we get
there right and I think the very
originally we only had just one product
line for the parents that you need to
address my own pain so I don't have to
oneself shop but that alone is not
enough then there is a go to market
strategy how can you acquire users
how can you acquire parents users how
can you onboard the providers how can
you design a business model that
everyone would say yes so that's kind of
also related is to be system design
right you want to design a distribute
systems all the parties all these
components of the system they have to
all the incentives and everything have
to align for the system to run smoothly
and similarly want you when we
design what you know we designed this
business we also designed a business
model in such way that all the parties
and it is involved in this business
system also all the incentives aligned
for the losers were the business model
is we take commission so here
so also researchers have the greatest
training to give the pitch about the
idea you know a good salesmanship
actually come from being a researcher
here's my pitch to the provider it's
completely free for you to list any
number fees for any number of your end
of your camp only when we bring you
enrollment and extra income we take a
very small cut oh you can only earn more
when working with six cricket that's for
marketing one line pretty quick right
and also we also provide a free online
registration service for the providers
to support especially if you're small to
mid-sized providers you can use our
online registration service for your
website and free for you to use because
we want to really support you